(tirs)dedededededededededededede
Daesh sont tombés, il y rererere
ans, plus de 50 000 djihadistes
envoyés dans ces cam
détention, au nord-est de laamas
étrangères. Bead'd'd'd'enfants
et des femmes de combattants,
qui se disent innocentes.
"S'il y a un enfer sur terre,
Kimberley Polman à notre
collègue MÈve Bédard,
en 2019. La femme serait une des
deux Canadiennes libéréemamamam,
avec deux enfants; ce
confirme son avocat.
"Sa santé est dans un état
abababable, dit-il, je suis
certain que c'est en grande
veut la ramener au pays".awawaw,
dans un recours collectif,
en Syrie. Il croit que
le Canada a les moyens
de tous les rapatrier., , , , ,g
Amnistie Inter. Canada francoph.
- Un remememement collectif
aurait été souhaitable
et est encore souhaitable.
du Canada, on parle de très peu
erererersonnes, contrairement
à d'autres pays, je pense
entre autres à la France.
la semaine dernière,55 ressortit
une quarantaine d'enfants.
Amnistie internationale,s,s,s,se
l'approche "cas par cas"
du Canada. Depuis quatre ans,
seulement deux enfants canadiens
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministCaCaCaCanada
- On est particulierement
préoccupé
sont là, mais, évidemment, on ne
commenteurururur des opérations.
- Une quarantaine de Canadiens
serait
dont 25 enfants.
- Je q q q que ces enfants
vont être très... sont et seron,
unununun autre enjeu parce que
plus ces personnes, plus cesntnt
des endroits extrêmementviviviv.
- Selon nos sources, la deuxième
femme libérée ce matin reviendra
à Montréal eseseses prochaines
heures, avec ses deux enfants,
nés en S
Elle pourrait faire face
à desatatatations criminelles.
- Ces personnes-là ont droit
à l
ont droit à avoir un procès
ju é é é équitable et,
le cas échéant aussi, d'avoir
et proportionnelle aux crimese .
MARCO MENDICINO, ministre
- C'est seulement après un
processus qui est géré par les
services policiers indépendants.
de rapatrier des combattants
djihadistes, en évoquant le
risque qu'ils représententtétét.
Aujourd'hui le ministre dit
qu'ils peuvent revenir quand
des enquêtes policièresntntntnte
sur de possibles crimes, commis
en Syrie.
Ici Sophie Langlois,
Radio